minneapolis is not the only city that is
bracing for this verdict philadelphia
chicago washington d.c
they have all activated national guard
troops think about that for just a
second jeff begays is outside
a minneapolis police precinct that has
been the target for protesters
jeff good morning i drove by that
precinct yesterday and boy was it
serious yeah it's certainly
serious looking good morning gail
welcome to minnesota where
state officials say that they are in a
crisis mode waiting for this verdict
with the rest of the world and here's
what that means there are about
3 000 members of the national guard here
in minnesota
and they are on duty and just yesterday
the governor
declared a public safety emergency
requesting law enforcement back up from
ohio
and nebraska national guard members are
stationed in front of businesses and
office buildings stores have been
boarded up buildings are surrounded by
razor wire state and local officials are
trying to prevent a repeat of what
happened last summer
after george floyd's death as protesters
took to the streets vandals damaged more
than one thousand buildings and
businesses causing an estimated 350
million dollars in damages
this mobilization as massive as it is is
being called operation safety net but
what activists here in minnesota are
seeing they are seeing something
entirely
different with the barricades and the
barbed wire and the national guard here
guarding things what they see
is the militarization of this city and
they say
that peaceful protesters are really the
ones being targeted
gail
all right jeff thank you very much